[Music]
we're getting married soon
we're supposed to get married but then
this little one came along former
bachelorette Ali Fedotowsky opens up to
et about her upcoming wedding - radio DJ
Kevin man oh can you tease your wedding
party
do we have any kaley cuoco in Ana Brides
began to look forward to
Cayley we'll be at the wedding but no
not in the wedding party my wedding
party is two people my sister my best
friend can I ask you about Haley's new
man Kirkuk have you met him are you a
fan she is so smitten and he is like
from what she's told me he treats her
like a lovely yes woman that she is
she's super happy and just hearing her
talk about him I feel like this guy is
like the guy for her any other bachelor
nation alumni on the guest list we
invited Julian Harris Trista Sutter and
Ryan Sutter the lows you know Andi
Dorfman and a bunch I'm gonna get
married
locally yes luckily I got a dress you
have your dress yet um I do I'm very
excited about it what else are you guys
wanting at your wedding or what are some
must-haves we don't build out a good
time so like we're having a live band
and didn't like lots of open you know
yeah have fun I think keeping the guest
list small was very important to me
roughly between like 85 to 95 people
photos so like I made sure to like it
the best photography team that I could
possibly find to be the flower girl she
was yes we're so excited what was it
about Kevin that made him the guy for
you
he's just my ABS a little best friend he
like respects me he makes me laugh what
are the things that you guys do for each
other they keep things romantic this is
gonna sound stupid but he does all my
laundry I would get very switched gender
roles like I like handle the finances
and like the bills like things that
normally like stereotypically the guy
does so wait and then he just of the
cooking and cleaning on the weekends he
makes me breakfast in bed
what's your specialty Oh
but what a guy he's the best
[Music]
you